let's let the siren go by then for sure
all right jimmy sir jimmy where'd you
grow up where are you from originally uh
naples florida
naples and uh tell me about your family
you had both your parents when you were
kids yeah
[ __ ] both of my parents have been drug
addicts their whole lives too
[ __ ] you know like since since first i
can remember you know
like my mom [ __ ] my mom gave me my first
life that no
my dad gave me my first hit or crack
[ __ ] 15
16. you know like i've always known my
parents are drug addicts
you know so honestly i feel like i'm
kind of like yeah that's where i meant
to be
but like see my whole family honestly
honestly every single one i know yes
yeah brother and sister sisters
yeah i have a five-year-old brother back
in florida and an older brother who died
from crohn's disease
but i never met him because my mom dcf
took him from my mom
oh really yeah so i'm pretty much only
child growing up you know
grew up like you know a nice nice
neighborhood you know just
like you know mom one dope dad not
around or either
mom not around and dad on dope so like
you're like
this is a mix like you know how far did
you go in school i graduated high school
yeah and what'd you do after that sad
stuff just started getting high
you know got lazy i i got a couple jobs
and then
ended up just saying like i got hurt at
work i thought i don't work this
conversation
you know like that's like the worst
thing for me you know getting paid for
free
sitting there and then you know just
[ __ ] blowing my money and you know
get a couple hundred bucks in the mail
go blow it and wait for the next check
you know and uh drugs started for you
what age
i i imagine early well yeah i mean like
fentanyl 16 which is my
my main my main problem like what i
really love like
but pretty much yeah everything starts
like i did everything that started
starting at 16 like i started smoking
spice
at like 13 14 in middle school because
it was legal in florida you know like
you can go buy the gas station k2 like
synthetic weed
and honestly like i i think like
sometimes that's what probably [ __ ] me
up because
me and my friends were smoking like a
quarter ounce in that [ __ ] a day you
know
how did you know 23. 23. you don't seem
like you've been doing all these heavy
drugs
yeah for seven years yeah
bro actually that's the whole reason i'm
out here bro i came out here to get
uh for treatment reasons you know like
you've odd before yeah plenty of times a
fentanyl here yeah so i know
i voted off heroin you know two bunches
i don't know i try to keep my parents
better you know like i'm not like
you know i don't know honestly like a
lot of people don't think that but like
you know
[ __ ] but i get that like [ __ ] i'm a
real deal drug addict bro
like i wish i wasn't
where are you staying now uh on the
streets bro
you have a tent or you're just like no
just wherever i have some people's
tents like that like i'm cool with that
like you know i just
you know whoever wants let me stay at
night you know i got some people that
take care of me
what uh what do you do for money hustle
bill
hustle and then sometimes you know i'll
have like a homeboy sent me some money
you know like
thank god like you know i'm thankful for
my friends like they helped me out a lot
how low have you gone for money bro
i've heard everything no i haven't gone
like to like
to get out of my like to do nothing like
be gay nothing against gay people but
like i'm stealing i'm a thief bro i've
lied
manipulated all that [ __ ] bro like
bottom of the bottom bro like
nothing i'm proud of definitely
nothing i'm proud of you do you feel
like you were loved when you were a kid
yeah but like not not love like not as
more
not like yeah somewhat like but
but but like not i don't know how to
explain it bro no
not as much as they love drugs you know
obviously
because to this day they're both my
parents are drug addicts you know and
like
problems still there's nothing i don't
know
i kind of feel like they're unfixable
you know at this point
yeah [ __ ] bro like honestly i really
wanted to get my [ __ ] together for my
little brother you know he's five
and i don't want him growing up like i
did bro
do you have any friends yeah i gotta i
got some friends you know not out here
you know all back home
what emotions do you deal with
like a lot of like depressed like
sadness you know i'm real depressed a
lot
you know i'm like i'm shh i get angry
sometimes but like i don't
i don't really take it out on anyone you
know it's usually like take it out
myself
but i'm real kind bro like you know i'm
respectful like
i don't i don't know i don't try to like
i try to like you know
reason with everyone you know sometimes
i'm too nice a lot of people tell me
like
well you're like way too kind you know
like i let people take advantage of me
but like more the emotions bro i'm just
really in my head a lot you know like
thinking like this shit's never going to
change you know yeah
did you feel like there's a chance
you'll never get away from drugs
yeah after watching your parents yeah i
should definitely you know i feel like
every day i feel like i'm unfixable
definitely because you know i've been to
plenty of treatment centers top end
you know get clean how long this i've
had it's probably 60 days you know
and you know i just get i get a little
cash in my pocket and i get bored
and i just which you know it's [ __ ]
like that and then
literally one time leads to back on the
streets you know
and then i get like [ __ ] comfortable
with being on the damn tent which you
know
i've never been like that you know like
i like i don't know why like
i don't know these past few runs i'm
like [ __ ] it you know in the streets is
like
you know i'm all right with sleeping in
that tent which usually you shouldn't be
you know
that's that's where i'm at you know you
still have contact with your family
yeah yeah definitely i talked to my mom
every couple
every day a couple days now through the
week and my dad talked to my dad a lot
you know
my dad he's a good dude you know he he
works his ass off and he does his thing
but like you know
he made it reason he's pretty much the
reason i graduated high school
he was really strict on me you know like
but like he just didn't know what i was
doing after school you know it's make it
to school
you're making school you're good you
know you get you get seasoning up you're
good
which you know that's pretty but like
after that you know i got my freedom and
that's pretty much where i started
[ __ ] up more you know
what do you worry about now my little
brother bro
my five-year-old brother and my future
definitely am i like you know my whole
family you know i want them to
i want them to do better
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life
yeah bro sorry
[ __ ] but i used to be really good sports
player bro
really good as you can see i'm like six
four you know
i was a big kid what was your sport
basketball basketball baseball
i was i'm left-handed you know at least
destroy every like i would be i'd be
like way too good for my age you know
and all the parents knew it bro i was
always
excelling doing good but
you know through my [ __ ] parents
actions like i ended up just moving
states and states and just
not going to school for months you know
just because because
like they wouldn't enroll me or
just [ __ ] like that bro you know
yeah i just and then honestly like i
grew up like
and then check that's the point where i
was like i didn't want to do nine to
five you know i want to sell drugs like
i thought that was like
[ __ ] thought that i was gonna do that
forever you know like
you know like be a badass kid like nah
because i should at one point bro
you know i also now it's a crack a day
like i'm not
i'm not proud of it at all bro you know
like i ruined a lot of people's lives
but that's how i used to think you know
[ __ ] now i wanted to [ __ ]
i don't know i know i just need to get
my [ __ ] together bro honestly
what do you think most people that don't
do drugs
don't understand about it about
addiction that it happened to anyone you
know like
it's it's it doesn't discriminate you
know like
you know like like it can happen you can
go get hurt you know you go to the
doctor and prescribe you
like it can happen to you to you you
know easily get painkillers
yeah that's right that's that's how my
parents have happened to my parents
you know it happens a lot of people
yeah [ __ ] yeah
do you do you suspect it's it's
something you
picked up genetically from your parents
or just the role models you had around
the house
genetically you know like a lot of
people always say yeah it's genetic but
no
i think it's more the role model thing
bro you know like
like because if my environment wasn't
the way it was i don't think i would
have did the [ __ ] i did
it be the way i am but you know it's all
my like i take
you know it's definitely my actions but
like the way like the [ __ ] i seen and
like you know like
just watching my parents pick up drugs
and watching the [ __ ] they do and
hearing stories you know like
definitely definitely took effect you
know thinking that's normal you know
like yeah that's normal you know i would
think that's the one but
in my in reality it's not you know like
no one should have to do that
what do you think might save you from
this
is there anything falling in love with a
girl bro
same girl for four years but when she's
she's on a drug addict she was at
florida state university
she's amazing you know like she stuck
with me through my addiction she wants
me to get clean but
you know i ended up [ __ ] she ended up
like breaking up me because i can't get
clean bro you know
i still talk to her and she still like
hopes to
actually get to like make [ __ ] work but
she just she wants me to get my [ __ ]
together
because you know she wants she no one
wants to be with [ __ ]
someone who only cares about right more
likely you'll take her down then she'll
exactly
exactly
you feel shame and guilt over all this
oh yeah definitely
a lot of people down but you know i got
i know i can fix it you know it's just i
got to do it
stop [ __ ] feeling sorry for myself
sometimes and just get up and do it you
know
what is your typical day consist what
does it look like you wake up in the
morning and wake up
usually dope sick go go make some
make a couple bucks and then get get my
fix and then
honestly you just you know just just
keep hustling during the day you know
just push time get time pushing by you
know you're just living day by day
yeah nothing yeah exactly same [ __ ]
every day
yeah sad but like
do you think getting like getting caught
boosting and then ending up in jail for
a few weeks already been caught bro i'm
not boosting but i've had i've been in
jail for months and months
didn't put the best time when i the best
thing the best time i ever did clean was
on probation i got almost almost a whole
year of cleaning about right i did
really good
yeah like but like i was just more of
the fear factor do this or go to jail
for a year
you know like or get hot like you fail
drug tests you're going like in florida
they take that [ __ ] real serious i don't
know about out here because like you
know they're they're lenient out here
because they have bigger crimes
and where i'm from they're they're
slamming people for like a dirty urine
you know like
you might go to prison for that [ __ ] and
i was like [ __ ] that you know like
do you have friends in high school that
are in a similar situation as you
a lot bro a lot of friends like my [ __ ]
my best friend is the one that got me
out here to go to treatment
he's uh pretty much the same just like
me you know
like a year or two older than me but
pretty much a lot of kids run from her
like
you know they ended up drug addicts you
know it's just it's a small little town
you know it's like it's really rich you
know it's like people like their
families are wealthy you know and you
don't have [ __ ] to do
[ __ ] to do you know it's like first
smoking a lot of weed
and then it's like oh you know here
let's [ __ ] taste some
anax and then oh then on the percocets
and then you're smoking percocets that's
like
a tinfoil you know then when you run out
of money it's the heroin
it's pretty much a cycle bill
what's been the hardest part of your
life
living like this like yeah the hardest
part of it bro is like
to to actually to [ __ ]
to just just to stop like i'm in love
with the drug but
honestly like just to like to get my
obsession off of it you know like
i can't like it's kind of hard you know
like
it takes over the way you think and the
way you feel
everything you know like it turns into a
whole different person because like when
i'm clean i'm a whole another person
how many years you've been living on the
street uh almost no
almost a full year now at first i wasn't
like you know in the tent and [ __ ] like
that i was like
you know i'm paying for hotels i was
stacking a little money
you know you know like trying to be like
have a somewhat of a life but now i'm
just full blown in the tent you know
no laundry like [ __ ] like that you see
yourself changing as you're living like
this
i do but i also see time taken by and
all these people out here that
were just like me you know and like had
it like had a chance and blew it you
know
now they're now they're doing it like
you know they're stuck content
you know they're content with their life
they're peaceful but they're not happy
you know
i want to be happy what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
and [ __ ] just more
to be honest it's like you know just
it's like
stay in school go to school and do like
do the right thing you know like don't
[ __ ]
this shit's not cool it's not fun you
will [ __ ] up your life
you know just like listen to your listen
to your elders that know
that know what they're talking about you
know and like you know and even if
they're younger you know like
you know just stop like i don't know
just like [ __ ]
you see a lot of people in your shoes
that you all got started with peer
pressure
yeah definitely definitely or just
sticking to you know be trying to be
cool
[ __ ] like that you know all right and
then you're like like 15 16 17 you know
like yeah and they
don't they don't they think it's cool
you know they see that music
music's a big [ __ ] thing like you
know people always want to be the next
thing
popping or something like i don't know
like yeah people are trying to keep up
with the next trend or something you
know drink it lean
like you know what [ __ ] that's like
doing heroin you know you get
[ __ ] and people don't realize the danger
yeah potentially [ __ ] you know do
[ __ ] do percocets for ten
seven days straight you know you're
gonna wake up addicted you're not like
you're not going to think you're like
but you're going to start feeling shitty
and you're going to need them eventually
you know just even
to start your day not even to get high
you know i don't even get high anymore i
just get
i get well yeah you just you just need
to get rid of that wow yeah
what do you wish was different about
your life maybe when you were a young
child
it might have helped parents my parents
weren't addicted yeah
well i wouldn't trade my parents you
know just because like
i just i know i love them to death you
know like you know but like
definitely like maybe like because i
lived i started
as a young kid i live with everyone else
but my parents my parents would put me
in
like to live with friends you know and
they try they they try to give me a
chance but
yeah i just wish i don't know maybe like
i had a different environment you know
and like you know like i know my parents
wish they did better but
i can't change that you know it made me
the person i am you know
i know i could i could i still have
plenty of time to fix it i just
you know i just gotta like i say get up
and do it you know
because i've had the opportunities i've
had plenty of people plenty
opportunities of like great people
trying to help
and i [ __ ] them up you know just blow
them or
[ __ ] just you know like not answer
you know
just or just [ __ ] up somehow
all right judy well thank you so much
for sharing your story no problem thank
you i wish you the best of luck
appreciate it i hope you hope you
straighten out sure
you